beneath this frozen facade greenland is
considered to have the last great
untapped reserves
of rare earth materials but its
significance goes far beyond that
in an election which will be watched
with interest around the world the
opposition
community of the people party secured a
stunning environmental victory
campaigning against the mining of the
minerals in spite of their value
on the grounds of pollution
i'm happy it's a great responsibility
that the voters have given us
but it's also a great opportunity to lay
the foundation for the future of
greenland
the minerals are needed for making
things like mobile phones
and the batteries for electric vehicles
it's known as
industrial gold but its exploration
comes at a cost
the opposition has not been against rare
earth minerals as such
that the opposition has specifically
been against that this mine would also
come
with uranium mining there are other
mines there where you can
go and look and dig for rare earth
minerals where you don't get uranium
as a by-product and where you don't get
the same
environmental consequences
western governments worry that china
which backs the australian mining
company
may be seeking to monopolize greenland's
rare deposits
giving it control over what is fast
becoming the world's most valuable
resource
social democratic party which lost the
election had supported the mine
saying it would bring jobs a boost to
the economy
and greater financial independence from
denmark
but their defeat is a resounding
reminder of the growing global
importance of green
issues in politics this result from
greenland
is a further sign that political
parties can campaign on environmental
issues
and win elections environmental policies
are
increasingly popular particularly
amongst young voters
however the election result is
complicated the freezing of the mining
plans could impact the availability of
crucial components
for low carbon technologies as the world
tries to cut
greenhouse gas emissions the environment
may be impacted in more ways than one
lisa holland sky news